une vingtaine d'air d'accueil destiné
aux gens du voyage sont recensés dans
les ivelines cela représente 403 places
le département doit obligatoirement
réaliser 224 places supplémentaires
ainsi qu'au moins de aires de grands
passage d'ici 2019 sur la route
nationale 10 dans la commune des essard
Lerois un terrain proche de l'actuelle
aire d'accueil est envisagé ce projet
est loin de faire l'unanimité en
décembre une pétition contre cette
implantation a été mise en place si elle
regroupe les communes des essardlereroi
LVI saintnon elle a été lancée par la
ville de manère dont l'espace commercial
est proche de ce site nous sommes
inquiets notamment bien sûr pour ce
secteur commercial avec l'arrivée de 300
à 400 Caravan et puis du environ 1000
personnes peut-être de mai à septembre
ou octobre de chaque année et puis
également le terrain n'est pas disposé
pour accueillir ce type de d'aménagement
les différentes communes mettent en
avant des difficultés écologiques avec
la proximité d'une rigole alimentant la
base de loisirs de cquenttin en Yveline
des pour le trafic routier mais aussi la
sécurité des familles qui résideraient
sur cette are la pétition a d'ors et
déjà recueilli plus de 3000 signatures
envoyé au préfet il n'a pas encore
statué lorsque je suis arrivé en août
j'avais dit qu'effectivement je prendrai
la décision puisque c'est une décision
qui relève de l'état de définir le
terrain ou les terrains mais en tout cas
le terrain susceptible d'accueillir une
aire de grand passage dans le sud des
ivelines d'ici la fin du mois de mars je
prendrai la décision sur l'aire de grand
pass du Sud desvelines entreetemps je
vais consulter encore la décision prévue
en novembre dernier avait été repoussée
à cause des attentats de Paris si les
communes de plus de 5000 habitants
participent au financement de l'air des
contreparties financières et des mesures
seront accordées selon le préfet qui
devrait bientôt officialiser son choix